hi i'm eric voss and the matrix the
watkowski cyberpunk masterpiece has for
the past 20 years inspired a revolution
in the philosophy and the aesthetic of
hollywood films and remain the go-to
blu-ray of every annoying college
roommate ever and as one of those
annoying college roommates myself i
decided to take a break from the usual
deep dives into superheroes dragons and
droids as philosophical as many of them
are to examine the matrix scene by scene
to explore its influences how it
influenced nearly everything that came
after it and all the hidden visual
secrets in this movie that you might
have missed the first time your friend's
older brother who wore sunglasses a lot
showed it to you the film opens from the
point of view of the matrix itself in
the form of this raining green code the
color green was chosen to reflect the
green tint of early monochrome computer
monitors and throughout this movie the
color green filters every scene that
takes place inside the matrix in order
to show its artificiality compared to
the real world which is tinted in the
color blue this imagery was inspired by
the opening credits of the famous 1995
anime ghost in the shell a hugely
influential manga and film series ghost
in the shell is set in the future where
humans are cybernetically enhanced and
their brains can be hacked it explores
the philosophy of artificial
intelligence and detached identity and
actually when pitching this movie to
producers the wachowskis showed them
ghosts in the shell and said that they
wanted to make something like that but
live action and as you watch both of
these movies the themes and many exact
shots are direct homages to that anime
the production designers made this
matrix code uniquely it's a custom
typeface made up of mirror images of
half width came the characters and
western letters and numerals the
designer actually said that he based the
code from his wife's sushi recipes the
mirror reflection of these characters
sets up the motif of mirrors which
appear over and over and over again
throughout the film this movie's
composer don davis applied this theme of
mirror reflection into his music in this
moment he alternates between the
different parts of the orchestra with
one note played by one instrument and
then the horns blasting that note back
at them it's in the key of e minor
and then with each successive matrix
film that came out the opening chords
ascend with reloaded ascending up a
whole step to f sharp minor
and revolutions up a half step to g
minor
the matrix is a story about perception
mirrors reflect a framed image of us in
a reality and that self-perception
assures us of our existence but as we
see throughout this movie perception
alone cannot determine reality and our
view of the world around us can be
manipulated this idea of perception
plays into this opening exchange between
cipher and trinity you like him don't
you
you like watching him don't be
ridiculous cypher teases trinity for
obsessively watching neo all while the
machines are watching both of them
through the code actually in a couple
minutes when trinity escapes the agents
say the informant was real confirming
that cipher was indeed the one behind
this trace he set up trinity to die here
and he's the one who told the agents
that their next target is neo we can't
see the area code of this phone number
but the script says it's 312 for chicago
the city scenes were shot in sydney
australia but the script makes specific
references to streets in downtown
chicago like wells in lake and neo's
boss is a photo of chicago in his office
the point of view swoops in through
these phone number digits and between
these lines of code we arrive in the
police flashlight representing the
matrix's searchlight as they hone in on
the ghost in their machine
trinity played by carrie anne moss
trinity is her hacker alias which all
the freed humans adopt because their
names in the matrix are their given
names by machines trinity is a reference
to the holy trinity one of the many
connections to christian theology in
this movie the holy trinity is the
father son of the holy ghost also
reflected in the room number here 303
and speaking of ghosts trinity's
fierceness here was modeled on major
kusanagi the main character of ghost in
the shell who similarly rocks short
black hair she breaks limbs she
acrobatically defies physics all while
her sexuality is on full display the
costume designer actually designed
trinity's clothes to look mercury-like
and oil slick in order to reflect
trinity's ability to slip through the
matrix's fingers matrix have fingers it
can make you feel good trinity gives us
our first look at bullet time in this
film a technique created by visual
effects supervisor john gaida who won an
oscar for his work gate accredited akira
director otomo katsuhiro and director
michelle gondry for this aesthetic it
was built on the old technique of
time-slice photography with an array of
cameras all pointed at an object except
now these cameras were timed one second
after each other and they combined these
still images with a tracking motion
camera so that they could create this
smooth slow motion glide reaching a
frame frequency of 12 000 frames per
second as opposed to the normal 24
frames per second in film they created
in their own words a visual analogy for
privileged moments of consciousness
within the matrix as characters exert
control over time and space trinity's
wire assisted martial arts here was
choreographed by hong kong action cinema
director yoon woo ping inspired by the
jet li film fist of legend and this kind
of choreography would go on to inspire
pretty much every action movie that came
after this including crouching tiger
hidden dragon and a random matrix shot
in charlie's angels and in shrek yeah
there was a matrix shot in like every
movie between 1999 and 2004. and
throughout this opening sequence the
background details actually tease the
coming story looking closely at
trinity's laptop she's reviewing neo's
records which are the same records that
the agents will later produce in neo's
file on the street there's a sign for
kung fu and as trinity leaps over the
rooftops there's a sign for guns and
ammo and these rooftops might look
familiar because they're the same ones
used for the production of the film dark
city which is another high concept story
about humanity being kept in a carefully
constructed illusion trinity escapes in
we meet neo keanu reeves whom this film
poses as a christ figure his client choi
says you're my savior man
my own personal jesus christ and
actually jesus sneaks into this movie a
lot
jesus christ he's fast you scared the
bejesus out of me neo's matrix name is
thomas anderson thomas could be a nod to
the new testament disciple doubting
thomas with neo being a doubting figure
until a miracle happens and anderson
means son of man and many have pointed
out that neo is of course an anagram for
that's right eno and the one neo is
running internet searches for morpheus
whom the matrix is labeled as a
terrorist in order to make it hard for
morpheus to slip in and out of the
matrix and free more humans his role as
this mysterious criminal mastermind is
another parallel to ghost in the shell
in which there was an entity known as
the puppet master who is later revealed
as a revolutionary liberator in using
news media to lie about morpheus is a
nod to the ministry of truth in george
orwell's 1984 which would use propaganda
disguised as news to control the public
and notice that neo lives in room 101 in
room 101 was the psychological torture
prison in 1984. morpheus's name comes
from greek mythology morpheus is a god
of sleep and dreams and here neo wakes
up from a dream his awakening here is
actually foreshadowing his greater
awakening in this film the first act
actually shows three false awakenings
from neo setting up his awakening from
the matrix leading into act two and then
his final awakening as the one in act
three neo keeps his discs in this book
simulacra and simulation by philosopher
jean beaujolais it's a deeply
influential philosophical work that the
wachowskis actually required the cast to
read buzuriara describes how the rise of
capitalism has led to a society in which
simulated copies of real things have
become our reality as the previous
reality that those simulations were
based on has faded from our memory his
example was disneyland which is kind of
a false dream world in which we seek to
recapture the joy of our childhoods that
in reality probably never existed even
the fairy tales of disney films are
really sugar-coated simulations of the
much darker source material but let's be
honest who's going to ride a ride called
hansel and gretel's it's a cannibalistic
world after all ironically neo has
hollowed out the pages of this text
which is another example of how human
culture has been gutted by technology
machinery disguising itself with the
shell of humanity neo says you ever have
that feeling
where you're not sure if you're awake or
still dreaming this question invokes the
thinking of philosopher rene descartes
who posed how can you be certain that
your whole life is not a dream like neo
here descartes used waking up but still
being in a dream as an example of not
being able to trust our senses or our
perceptions as the basis of our
realities in descartes first meditation
he hypothesized that the perceived world
might be actually a comprehensive
illusion created by an evil demon to
deceive us neo's screen told him to
follow the white rabbit du jour's tattoo
here but also a nod to lewis carroll's
alice in wonderland a recurring allusion
in this movie to the surreal trip
through realities morpheus actually
brings up alice later and rabbits show
up on that tv in the oracle's home and
of course the amorphous mirror parallels
alice's looking glass at the club neo
meets trinity
most guys do
when the wachowskis made the matrix they
then identified as the wachowski
brothers but have since come out as
trans women and this line from trinity
is one of many examples of androgyny and
gender dysphoria in the film similarly
the character switch was actually named
as such because originally the character
was going to switch genders when they
went in and out of the matrix living as
the gender that they see themselves as
in their mind's eye neo's boss is a near
doppelganger for hugo weaving as agent
smith you have a problem with authority
mr anderson like in the play peter pan
the authority figure of mr darling the
kid's father is parallel to the
authority villain of the surreal world
captain hook jay and barry actually
established that the two characters
should be played by the same actor and
similarly here the surreal world villain
is based on a baseline fear of authority
that the character starts with and while
be reprimanded neo is distracted by the
squeaks of the window washers reflecting
the distractions that clarify his
metaphorical view of the outside world
and also setting up the scaffold as
morpheus's escape plan later and you'll
notice that neo's suit fits them
awkwardly the customer intentionally
dressed them to look uncomfortable
disheveled and out of place neil gets
arrested and his holding cell appears on
these video monitors with the point of
view returning to the machines in this
big brothery and surveillance style
these screens actually look a lot like
the ones in the architect's room in
matrix reloaded we might be seeing from
his point of view in this moment his
wordy to explanation that neo is
actually the sixth generation of
anomalies was originally going to be
revealed in this first film but it was
shelved for the second one there's some
interesting details in neo's paperwork
here it says that he attended owen
patterson high named after the film's
production designer and his passport
expiration date is september 11 2001
which is just one of those uncanny
coincidences that i'm sure no conspiracy
theorist has ever gone about the agents
melt neo's mouth shut which is really a
bizarre and seemingly unnecessary
restraint which really is used to make
neo dismiss them bugging him as a
nightmare it's also an homage to the
science fiction novel i have no mouth
and i must scream neo gets picked up by
trinity switch and apoc and in the green
tint of the coloring the falling rain
from the bridge and on the car windows
echoes the imagery of the green matrix
code since again this is really what all
this imagery is made of switch says
listen to me comfortable copper top is
their slang term for humans still
plugged into the matrix which are
essentially copper top duracell
batteries for the machines after
debugging him they bring him to morpheus
played by lawrence fishburn he begins to
explain the matrix it is the world
that has been pulled over your eyes to
blind you from the truth like everyone
else you were born into bondage born
into a prison that you cannot smell or
taste or touch
a prison
for your mind this concept is inspired
by other cyberpunk fiction like william
gibson's neuromancer which also used the
term the matrix this way and lp davies
also used the term matrix in the white
room earlier than that gibson said that
the matrix was actually closer
thematically to the writing of philip k
dick famous sci-fi author behind similar
works that ended up getting made in the
blade runner many other things that
we've seen and loved dick said in a 1977
conference we are living in a
computer-programmed reality
and the only clue we have to it is when
some variable is changed
and
some alteration in our reality occurs
the wakowskis later manifests this
concept with the black cat the glitch
signaling a manipulation of reality and
this idea of a mind prison and illusion
was also explored in plato's allegory of
the cave in which prisoners were chained
in a specific way so that their only
perception of reality was shadows on the
cave wall projections of the reality
instead of the reality itself so that in
plato's mind this philosopher's mission
like morpheus is to intellectually
unchain the unenlightened so that they
can see the world as it really is
morpheus offers neo a choice between the
red pill and the blue pill and when neo
chooses red his reflection on the left
lens shows his hand reaching for it
while the lens on his right shows no
movement at all from the left hand it
reflects how the red pill represents
reality as it is in the blue as a
separate reality in which neo stays in
the simulation the false reality the red
pill was actually a tracer so they could
pinpoint neo's body pod in the real
world making the machines think his body
was dead so they unplug and flush them
this unplugging when you think about it
was actually set up in the opening
minutes of the film hey look it just
sounds to me like you know you need to
unplug man the mirror glass sticks to
neo's flesh to reflect this simulated
reality melting around him as morpheus
says this have you ever had a dream neo
that you were so sure was real
what if you were unable to wake from
that dream
how would you know the difference
between the dream world and the real
world morpheus is once again bringing up
descartes dream argument which has also
been referred to as the zhuangzi paradox
zhuangzi argued while he is dreaming he
does not know it is a dream only after
he wakes does he know it was a dream and
someday there will be a great awakening
when we know that this is all a great
dream neo wakes up in the real world in
his biopod the vast field where humans
are farmed the aesthetic here is
compared to the imagery of m.c escher
and the film metropolis the fusion of
man and machine this pod was actually
constructed to look dirty and used since
when you think about generations of
human batteries would have lived and
died in this thing keanu reeves
reportedly lost 15 pounds and shaved his
whole body to give neo an emaciated look
or maybe keanu just did this already and
wikowski's were like oh okay yeah we'll
use that neo flushes and gets picked up
by the hovercraft the nebuchadnezzar
named after the ancient babylonian king
mentioned the bible as having a dream
that he can't remember he searches for
an answer there's actually a plaque on
this ship made in the usa year 2069 mark
3 number 11 model which could be another
biblical reference in mark chapter 3
verse 11. it says and whenever those
possessed by evil spirits caught sight
of him they would fall down in front of
him shrieking you are the son of god i
don't know it kind of sounds like a neo
thing the ship was designed to have a
patched up look with wires running
everywhere spare parts that don't match
other parts similarly their clothes are
all worn down and hole-filled morpheus
introduces all these crew members and
they all have you know their hacky
computer names mouse cipher switch apoc
which is actually short for apocalypse
because in the expanded matrix universe
literature apoc had written the four
horsemen virus there's also tank and
dozer who were born in the real world
they don't have holes they upload neo's
consciousness to the construct a
blinding white space the wawkowski said
that kubrick's 201 space odyssey
inspired their visual style and this
room evokes the simulated home that the
enlightened 5th dimensional beings
constructed for bowman neo touches the
chair and asks this isn't real neo
questioning the reality of the chair
evokes the concepts of philosopher
george berkeley who said to be is to be
perceived suggested that a chair is
actually a collection of ideas morpheus
shows neo the real world in the year
2099. welcome
to the desert
of the real the desert of the reel is
actually a direct quote from bulgaria
arts book that i brought up earlier
morpheus walks near through an
abbreviated history of the war between
man and machines and actually other
matrix related works go deeper into this
history apparently it all started with
simple ai robots designed for manual
labor until one of them murdered its
owner to prevent being scrapped led to
conflicts with robots rights activists
and robot armies and eventually war
similar actually to isaac asimov's
irobot in addition to the other
influences i brought up this movie's
concept was actually similar to a
storyline in doctor who the deadly
assassin as he struggles to accept this
truth neo gets to know tank who tells
them about the last human city zion we
see that in the sequels zion gets its
name from the bible the original name of
jerusalem zion also refers to the
kingdom of heaven and christian theology
in the old testament god banished the
people from zion destroying their temple
and they were transported by
nebuchadnezzar to babylon where they
remained for 70 years until they could
return which is very similar to these
wandering exiles tank runs neo through
combat training and one of the screens
shows drunken boxing the fight
choreographer yoon directed the early
jackie chan film drunken master in which
chan masters drunken boxing in addition
to that neo learns jiu jitsu savate
kempo taekwondo and i know kung fu neo
and morpheus spar and yoon actually had
to alter the choreography so that
instead of fully hitting each other
reeves and fishburn would pull their
punches and stop just short of hitting
their faces because when they were fully
fighting they kept bruising each other
up and injuring each other further now
the matrix's second act keeps us
guessing with whether or not neo is the
one like he seems to defy physics too
well during his sparring with morpheus
but then in the following scene he falls
in the jump trial morpheus walks neo
through the agent defense program with
the woman in the red dress now notice
the extras in the scene morpheus walks
through them easily but they slam into
neo to show his awkwardness hacking into
the matrix but also all of these extras
are duplicates there's two sailors two
nuns two bald guys they cast doubles of
everybody they did this because mouse
designed this program and it's an
example of how he had to double up on
character designs because of their
lesser processing power than what the
matrix has mouse uses the woman in the
red dress to distract neo but the
program also works on us too the woman
turns into an agent to show that agents
can turn into anyone actually if you
remember the scene in which neo was
arrested by the agents you can spot a
few women in red dresses around him in
the frame morpheus tells neo that sooner
or later someone is going to have to
fight them notice that as morpheus says
this the reflection in his sunglasses
frames neo with agent smith's gun in his
face foreshadowing smith shooting neo in
the third act the moment that neo
victoriously fights back and defeats
smith now neo catches up on cipher
frightening him notice that cipher
immediately closes a screen claims that
the matrix code that he's looking at
translates to women a blonde brunette
redhead but cipher was actually setting
up his meeting with the agents which he
does in the next scene with joey pants
eating the most delicious piece of steak
i've ever seen smith reveals his matrix
name mr reagan and cipher wants to be
reinserted into the matrix kind of like
federal witness relocation as someone
important like an actor which perhaps
could be a nod to ronald reagan an actor
who actually ended up being someone very
important that's right back to the
feature reference ronald reagan the
actor cipher is an example of the
institutionalized human that smith later
refers to in his monologue like the
humans in the early betas of the matrix
cipher rejects his freedom and he
prefers the walls of a prison he wants
to be chained up in plato's cave
watching shadow puppetry or simply he
just wants to be the average person who
thinks disneyland's pretty great sorry
bulgeriard like bourgeois they take neo
to the oracle and on the car ride the
passing city casts no shadow or light
shifts on the actors faces clearly green
screen but no effort made to disguise it
perhaps to further highlight the
matrix's artificiality which now looks
even more fake to neo as he's back in it
though oracle's lobbies guarded by this
blind man perhaps it nodded the oracle's
inspiration from greek mythology the
oracle teresius who was blind the man
actually nods at morpheus perhaps seen
more than we realize and perhaps
foreshadowing neo's blindness in the
sequels a blindness that also gave neo a
more powerful kind of perception
interesting visual detail here when
morpheus shows near the door for him to
walk through the reflection shot on the
doorknob hides the film camera in plain
sight the crew covered the camera with a
jacket and a fake green tie half to
match morpheus's tie to blend it in with
morpheus after bending spoons with the
other potentials neo meets the oracle in
the kitchen she's wearing green and the
walls and countertops are green along
with the fixtures and living room it
paints the oracle as a kind of earth
mother of the matrix protecting it and
guiding the anomalies that are born
inside of it the song that she's
listening to is a swing band cover of
i'm beginning to see the light which neo
does in this scene the oracle points out
the sign above the door which translates
to know thyself it's a reference to the
inscription above the entrance of the
oracle of delphi and greek mythology
know thyself as an ancient greek
aphorism of philosophers like socrates
and plato according to legend when
socrates visited the oracle of delphi he
claimed to know nothing and the oracle
of delphi replied that he was the wisest
man on earth and this oracle keeps this
sign to remind visitors to be aware of
their own ignorance which neo actually
does pretty effectively here do you
think you are the one
honestly i don't know so neo's doubt
makes him wise in this moment the oracle
tells him that he is not the one because
he's waiting to find a reason to step up
as a hero that makes his oneness his
choice as opposed to something
predestined talk more about that in a
second the agents and police ambushed
them thanks to cypher this hotel is
actually the same one that they brought
neo to before when they unplugged him
and in this lobby neo notices the cat
glitch deja vu signaling a change once
again a nod to philip k dick's line but
also to the old superstition of black
cats being bad luck we actually learned
and reloaded that real world
superstitions in legends like witchcraft
vampires werewolves they're actually
surviving code from previous
incarnations of the matrix everything
goes to mouse dies and there's a little
moment where morpheus asks for cipher's
phone and you can see cipher fumbling
around for it before trinity hands hers
over because of course cipher dropped
his phone in the trash to signal the
agents they tried to escape their crawl
space in the walls the cop who finds
them turns into agent smith which the
designers show by lines of green matrix
code crawling down his face morpheus
sacrifices himself to let neo escape
cipher attacks tank and dozer he pulls a
plug on apoc and pulls a plug on not
like this switch in when he's just about
to unplug neo he says that there would
have to be some kind of miracle to stop
him from doing it and sure enough tank
stops him so after we saw the oracle
tell neo that he was not the one this
movie restores our hope briefly that he
still could be agent smith lectures
morpheus about how early versions of the
matrix were a utopia but it was a
disaster because those humans rejected a
perfect world and instead preferred one
that was more chaotic cruel filled with
suffering like the one that we know this
idea actually was influenced by the
philosopher emmanuel kant who argued
that people are their own agents of
deceit that it's easier for humans to
live in a world of lies and so that for
them to know truth they must choose to
openly pursue it smith compares humanity
to a virus that simply multiplies and
destroys but then later smith sends out
the other agents to emotionally growl at
morpheus that he can't stand the smell
of the matrix disgusts him and he's
outgrown it he wants to escape it so at
the end of this movie after neo destroys
him smith actually returns and reloaded
with neo's humanity imprinted on him he
becomes the exact destructive virus that
he accused humans of being neo and
trinity set out to save morpheus with a
lobby shootout that was actually in many
ways a live-action recreation of the
third act shootout of ghosts in the
shell they detonate the bomb in the
elevator to get the roof and neo
whispers there is no spoon mentally
preparing himself to do what that kid
told him to do rather than bending the
bullets to dodge them neo bends himself
literally benning himself giving us the
iconic bullet time dodging bullet shot
of this film but this also reminds us of
the earlier scene with morpheus morpheus
told him that when he was ready he
wouldn't have to dodge bullets so as
cool as this is we know that neo is
still waiting for his final awakening
they rescue morpheus with the helicopter
which crashes into the side of a
building morphed to trinity get out but
neo runs into smith in the subway
station they fight and leads through a
chase through the city looking for an
exit leading him back to the same heart
of the city hotel where the agents
chased trinity in the opening minutes
notice how smith looks up and recognizes
this building that explains how he knew
to wait for neo in room 303 exactly
where the hard line is also this hotel's
name heart is exactly where smith shoots
neo so neo dies and the sentinels close
in trinity confesses to neo that the
oracle said that she would fall in love
with the dead man who would become the
one her kiss here is another example of
gender reversal in this film trinity is
the prince who kisses the dead princess
to bring him back to life so trinity's
resurrection power fulfills neo's christ
journey resurrecting with the power of
the holy trinity the moment neo stops
the bullets don davis's score actually
takes on a spiritual course and really
cool detail here when it cuts back to
them watching and disbelief as this
happens on the matrix code on the
screens the shaking camera from the
sentinels breaking in does the slightest
sign of the cross up down left right
spectacles gestures wild watch but
despite neo seeming to fulfill his
prophecy to become the one it's worth
remembering that in the sequels this
prophecy is revealed to be a lie a
narrative invented by the architect in
the oracle in order to seek out the
anomaly in each generation of the matrix
and reset everything but neo choosing to
be the hero makes him the anomaly that
changes everything bringing us back to
descartes most famous for his maxim i
think therefore i am neo isn't the one
because an external system told him he
was he is the one because he decides to
be the final shot of the film returns
the point of view of the matrix itself
running another trace program on a phone
call except now the program crashes
finding an anomaly that it cannot
control this city block will later be
the exact location where neo ends the
war by saving the matrix from the smith
virus neo hints at this future piece
with his final words to the machines
where we go from there
is a choice i leave to you it's one
final homage by the wakowskis to their
spiritual ancestor ghost in the shell
which ended with a very similar line as
the rebellious anomaly of that system
broke free
and where does the newborn go from here
the net is vast and infinite the matrix
would go on to inspire everything
inception avatar westworld black mirror
and at least two cameron diaz ripoffs of
trinity's jump kick and some super
annoying 4chan threads but in this
moment the net was vast and infinite and
the matrix stood out as a defiant game
changer that showed us the door a door
for us to walk through so we hear new
rock stars like to do deep dive analyses
of all kinds of movies we broke down
nolan's dark knight trilogy we do the
marvel films star wars but these classic
film analyses are kind of hard for us to
make time for but we want to do a lot
more of them so help us out and comment
down below to let us know what movie you
would like to see us break down next you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
at eavos and subscribe to new rockstars
for more stuff you missed from the stuff
you loved you know what thanks for
joining me as i break down the matrix
which is a movie i just love so much
that i made a lot of crappy stunt videos
with my friends where we gave ourselves
a lot of back damage and for my 9th
grade drama class i performed agent
smith's monologue how did it go you ask
it was a disaster yeah yeah it was
you